who do you think is at the head of the
household who do I think is at the head
of the household in what
sense like a car has one driver seat
it's got one steering wheel there's a
passenger seat there's a trunk there's
back seats like who drives a car like
who's the head of the household that
depends I listen I don't not going to
sit here and tell other people to to
make decisions like the way I would I
think that in terms of children
generally it's the wife in terms of
what's for dinner it's generally the
wife in terms of you know who who brings
home the bacon that's who in the
relationship there's plenty of women who
bring home the bacon I'm not going to
sit here and tell you one size fits all
that's the difference between us you're
trying to say that all women I'm asking
you for your opinion on you know who
should be the head of the household
whoever in that relationship is the one
that takes that role on I mean what does
that mean pay the bill no but do you
think that women should be at the head
of the household if that is what they
want in the relationship I mean it's you
think that women like being the of
household I'm sorry do you think women
like being at the head of the household
um I know I don't necessarily know I
love love uh being able to just be the
wife I don't think that being the head
of the household is necessarily
something we strive for I think that
it's something that again we've been put
into a position we have nowhere to go we
have no way to win in this war there's
nothing that I'm saying here tonight
that it's like
um you're something has to give you
can't have it all if you are going to be
a stay-at-home mom if you're going to
take care of your kids and you're not
going to have a job then yes you
probably are going to have a man who's
going to take care of the bills and is
going to want to be the head of the
household and that's wonderful and you
should if that is what is right for you
you should absolutely go down that path
yeah my winner I married a man the first
time around the father of my children
who when I married him wasn't wasn't a
bread winner and I told him I'm going to
stay home because my kid's not going to
go to daycare I want raise my child and
I started a business from my dining room
table because I wanted to stay with my
child I wanted to be this the business
that he's running right now it is okay
so so he's taking care of the business
you guys have settled that right broke
up yep yeah so the reason why I'm asking
you about you know like who leads
because there has to be a leader right
and I'm getting a lot of like it's I
mean I'm just going to call it wishy
washer like it's well you know whoever
needs to be the head of the household or
whoever's the best fit sort of thing and
it's like no I we kind of have to Define
these terms right like like who should
be you know to Define Captain who's
who's who's the one that's going to be
driving that ship because when women do
it us the ones to decide this I think
that people in ask you for your opinion
because you disagree with some of the
things that I'm talking about so I'm
trying to the way you talked about women
I'm not this the relationship aspect of
it I like be whatever you I think you
took it out of context is what you did
because I didn't actually say that women
have no value after 23 that's what you
said I just said that women hit two
walls and the walls based on their looks
because women are Beauty objects to men
which we've already established because
you put on makeup because you put
yourself in a bikini to sell yourself
like if you didn't care about your look
to get a man I was selling myself to get
my political points across I was selling
myself to get an ideology across I but
you know that your looks get the
attention of men right I mean like your
second husband chose you because of your
looks you understand that of course
I'm sure he chose me for my looks and
many other things right so take let's
take a pause on this yeah I wanna I want
to get Brianna's thoughts on on sort of
this discourse this back and forth
that's been going for the last you know
little while and just kind of see what
you're thinking see what your uh
positions are when it comes to some of
this
stuff my position on what who should be
the head of the house on anything if
it's head of household if it's you know
do you agree that we're going in the
opposite directions for you know minut
women and and why that might be um you
know anything that you've kind of heard
over the last like 10 or 15 minutes
maybe that you want to chime in on okay
um I understand where what Martha is
saying but for me personally I would
want the man to be the head of the
household I think a lot of women not all
I can't speak for all women but I think
a lot of women that's what they want
they want a man that allows them to be
feminine and they don't want to have to
be the one that makes all the decisions
and I certainly don't want to be the
bread wunner of my house especially as a
teacher like that would be awful um so I
for me personally I think the man should
be the head of the household that's what
I would want as far as are we
going the opposite direction of what we
should be going as in
women working women not being together
and breaking apart from one another or
or is well maybe I want I want to
Sidetrack and ask a second question
because I think what you said right
there is really interesting interesting
to me okay I want to ask a followup
because you you kind of said from your
experience your perspective and I know
we're not asking you to speak for all
women here but in your perspective you
think that generally women want to be
led not to be the leaders but do you
find because I do but I want to see if
you do I find that generally what's
being preached in mainstream media
mainstream society that that's no longer
acceptable or it's not even okay to want
that it has to be
go make the money go get the degrees go
be the entrepreneur protect yourself
from men so it's interesting so when
you're hearing from women that are
saying hey like I don't want to be the
leader I want to be led is that your own
just experience is that circles of
friends or or where are you sort of
getting these
ideas that's my personal opinion as well
as I see I mean I've seen Tik toks of it
I've seen people in my own life people
that I work with
with but at the at the flip side I do
know women who they have no problem
stepping into that head of the household
role and they enjoy doing that but for
me personally I don't want that that's
not what I want to embody I don't like
having to be the person that is going to
make all of the decisions that has to be
relied on solely
financially is that the way that most
women think do you ladies think or
no I mean doesn't everyone don't you
wouldn't you
want some like somebody who like not
have to worry financially I don't think
it's necessarily about the person
wouldn't you want to not have to worry
about finan I've never married a man
that was rich when I married him so I
wouldn't know that like I I just
intuitively I would rather be rich than
poor I don't I mean I don't know what
the the no I think I could probably
distill the way that you see it I mean
you know you can correct me if I'm wrong
but I but you seem to see yourself as a
King maker right I don't see myself as a
king maker I see myself as hang on a
second you
put sure I see myself as a stereotypical
woman of yester year one who married
somebody and then supported him through
his goals so for example um didn't you
say something along the lines of of like
every every partner that you've had
you've you my two husbands raised them
up yeah yes that is my job as their wife
my job as their wife I just sort of
summarize it as like you see yourself as
a king maker right I never said it that
I was a kingmaker I said my job you
didn't say that but I'm just summarizing
it that way if that's how you feel my
job as their wife no that's what I think
is to be the person that takes care of
the things to make them to allow them to
pursue their own passions to pursue the
things that make them them I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out